all right Kelly Kelly where'd you grow
up where you from I grew up in Queens
New York I was born in Brooklyn and tell
me about your your childhood you grew up
with course your pants
I grew up know I grew up with this my
mom my dad was in federal prison I have
four brothers and one sister
how was he how was your childhood Oh my
childhood was on it wasn't a normal
childhood
I have four brothers who have had sex
with me before I even knew what sex was
I've been in three mental institutions
before the age of eleven I came to
California at the age of 14 my father
came to New York and got me and from
there I was pregnant by my brother so
you had sex with older brothers all four
my brothers aren't going and I didn't
tell anybody because I was always like
the black sheep of the family so me and
my mom weren't close she was close to
her boys and that's why you know I'm
real time police today so anyway um my
father came and got me at the age of 14
and brought me to California but I was
pregnant by my brother that but I didn't
know I was pregnant and he didn't know I
was pregnant but I carried real small so
I never told anybody I was pregnant and
when he found out I was pregnant he left
me and an apartment and the manager of
the apartment called the police because
she would see me all the time and the
police came and got me and I went to a
foster home in Compton no adage before
that was 14 so I went to a foster home
in Compton I had the baby I don't know
the baby but my foster father got me
pregnant in the foster home so I have a
boy and a girl
but I don't know either one of them Wow
well what did you start having sex it
was early on I don't even know their age
because my brothers had started I don't
think they really knew what they were
doing but maybe they saw somebody doing
it but it went on and on and on
time I was like up here looking at my
brother here on top of me in the
basement yeah but anyway so I had the
baby for my foster father had a girl and
the little girl actually went to the
foster home
that I was in so actually her dad was
the foster father but no one knew
because no one never told anyone and
from there I went to another foster home
they tried to take me to a group home I
ran away and I've just kind of been like
on my own since then you know doing what
I need to do just to get by I've been
homeless for like 15 years now I have
that they got me in a SRO over here and
that's about how he goes you know I've
done just what I had to do to get by
I've had drug addictions you know but
I've had syphilis I've had dizzy you
know but I just make it you know the
best way I can make it there hold it you
know I'm 56 years old yes and so you
have two children that you need oh I
don't know yeah they're like mmm
30-something 30-something oh this one
might be like 38 36 maybe he was born in
77 and one was born in 78 79 theater
tried to present no no because my life
is not but I mean it wasn't together
then and it's really not together now
does it ever been no well for two years
it was for two years
somehow those two years I went through a
drug program the Rena be and I stay
sober for two years and how was that
that two years was actually pretty
alright it was kind of nice but I had a
job then and the company hire it was a
clean in Java as janitorial but the
company that I work for
I guess they bid for the company again
or whatever and they lost so I was
getting all laid off and I just went
back to smoking yeah do you ever have
contact with maybe your other family I
do have family I still have four
brothers and a mother but my family is
if I find everyone's like in contact
with my mom but no no no none of the
siblings are in contact with each other
so like if my mom tells me maybe my
brother Damon is doing this or that
that's how I know what's going on and
how do you like so how do you spend your
your day no mostly Jess are using a
drugstore that's it okay
yes and what do you how do you support
yourself Wow I do whatever I need to do
to support myself if it's have sex okay
that's cool if it's still something you
know taking if somebody's slipping hey
you know it's that mean that's just how
it is you know but looking back to your
life what do you what do you think was
what wouldn't what would have changed
your half of the path of your life Louis
what would he change the path of my life
just I don't know if my childhood you
know if if everything will it just been
different because the way everything
happens is messed up you know when I
know it's played I got some issues about
it I really don't know all of them but
some of them I know but I don't really
like to blame it on my childhood but
really into it because I'm an adult now
you know so my childhood is gone and I'm
still like [ __ ] up yeah did you ever
have a dad
I have a father my father came and got
me at the 18 yeah he came out of prison
right
he can't yeah he was in federal prison
but I guess he had been out of federal
prison
and me and my grandmother which was his
mother my grandmother was always like
that's my grandmother and I mean she got
in touch with him because that's her
sign and I guess told him I was having a
lot of problems or whatever
and so he came so so maybe the best
years your life for those two years
where you were clean yeah those were
those were the most peaceful I can
remember that peace inside yeah that's
cool
what do you see for your future do you
ever see yourself getting clean mmm
getting off the street okay I know
you're you're in an SRO which is not on
the street technically but but you're
still in serum I don't know if I'll ever
get clean I've been clean I've been to
other programs and it's always kind of
look at it like it would God but if God
works it out then God works it out you
know and that's just how I go all right
Kelly well thank you so much for sharing
your story and good luck with with with
your life and wherever you go from here
hey thank you
you